岩井ば全部明治参与はこんにちははじめ社長です
朝もうすぐ中でございますなんで僕にちょっと早朝シューティング部っていう
チャンネルの純樹さん遊びに来てますたまに北バスケットボールをしてる人なんです
けどもそれぞれちょっと今ぼく家に泊まってて僕の新規には今回初めて着たので僕んで
の作りはまた車
しっかり分かっていません初見でございます走友会が今ちょっとコミュにで飯を買いに
行ってるんでかなり時間があるんですけども
ちょっと変えに転生的なことしてあげようか思っておりました今回こういうものを
見つけました
どこでもドアノブ中でどこにでもつけてどの部みたいで裏ちょっとシールとかもあるの
でどこでも貼れます
わけわからない壁とかねこうなんか床とかに適当
に僕んちのんだボケ感ともに貼ってみ手順者さんは多分僕の予想だと
アホなんですよ絶対はから殺すだ適当なとこに貼ってるどんな場があるとそれすらも
多分多分どうだと思っちゃってるワード某回すと思うので人はぞ孔部があると何でも
ドアに見えちゃうのかっていうとアホかどうかの検証ちょっとしてに開けると思います
かなり年上です
ぶん殴られたですねもうもう入ってくるんで早速ちょっと仕掛けて行きたいと思います
ではいこかもよ
goo
ん
殺すぞ
んんん
ん
はぁ
うれしい
ええええええ
ものでしょう殺す者
re ん
ん
えっ
done
編曲だろなんですけど殺すだーっ
もおおおおおおおおおおおおおおお
なあ
はあああっもう join 所
なにがー
ん
補助でタマ姉こそだっ
何とっ
はいはい
サブちゃんのです痛いので待っているセレブ
何でもです
そちらもバス停はこれからしゃべったりそういうのがある
ハマりしないですか
it
ん
def